musique nous sommes vendredi 70 par les
musiques lou doillon
bonsoir et bk lou doillon deuxième album
oui le premier gros succès gros succès
puis c'est impossible à recréer cette
magie le y avait comme un contexte aussi
s'il a fait de johanne doyon la fille de
jane birkin la demi soeur de charlotte
gainsbourg puis toute sa vie elle a
toujours été un peu de son propre aveu
le vilain canard que jamais réussi à
rien que ce soit la comédie ou un jour
le maillot de l'afrique
oui hélas il y avait ce premier album
que les six en anglais qui est arrivé
comme une surprise qui nous a séduit et
c'est avec cet album et qu'elle a trouvé
sa place et arrive aujourd'hui les lots
un bon deuxième j'ai quand même beaucoup
aimé on écoute world stats
ce sera une
tout au nôtre oui tout en anglais et cet
accent british un peu comme sa maman moi
ce que j'aime valeur ou d'enfants
meurent on parle de musique ce qui nous
intéresse que c'est sa voix rauque
presque cassée une fille qui adore les
artistes canadiens pour elle c'est serré
fluence est vraiment patrick roy leonard
cohen
rufus wainwright au canada enregistré
avec un canadien auquel est venu ici à
montréal en plein hiver 2014
pour cet album avec leur coque denver et
c'est ce qu'il voulait c'est un cliché
de le dire mais les grands espaces
l'horizon puis elle a cette capacité
oui avec beaucoup d espace danse dans
cette musique là qui est un peu du fond
cousine et surtout à extérioriser est
cristallisée je dirais ses faiblesses et
ses fragilités moi j'ai beaucoup aimé l
etat stéréo pop ce soir 20h sur les
ondes
c'est dur un deuxième album et elle
passe le test et lou doillon j'avais
beaucoup recommandations absolument
rebecca le groupe saint germain que je
connais oui il ya dix ans les albums
doubles
je me rappelle m'être de sable non non
mais je suis si vous aimez moi j'ai
peut-être moins aimé que vous mais ouais
trois millions d'exemplaires de cet
album tourist avec cette chanson avant
toulouse le bund
ado ok moi je parle de touristes en
bronze rouge est ce qu'on découvre qu'on
se bouge
juste pour ce sera un beau champion ok
ce
un succès qui a fait de lui le porte
étendard de la french touch vous devez
qu'il n'a pas et a presque disparu
pendant quinze ans plus revient avec un
nouvel album intitulé blood blues
je sais pas si ça va vous plaire on est
encore dans le jazz lange
mais je dirais c'est son album africaine
c'est vraiment un album que ben oui
c'est un deuil et a laissé espérer du
mali on écoute blues très bien ça va
tant que je suivais de chansons balafon
kora salut après six ans de recherches
est très méticuleux et très pointilleux
saint germain est enregistrée chaque
musicien séparément pour construire
c'est loupé c'est bouclé siem de la
musique malienne c'est que c'est
cyclique c'est la lexus de l'effet trans
c'est vrai que ça appelle à l'être
ça sonne un peu plus qu'à je remarque
dans son feuillage heures mais oui moi
je trouve que ça on dirait du amadou et
mariam remix et puis tant qu'à y être
j'aimerais mieux entendre amadou et
mariam on veut ouvert ça c'est peut-être
l'effet fraîcheur d'une volonté qui
manque encore une fois ça c'est
impossible à recréer on se laisse sur
l'essor boulet et sans boulet qui
sortent un nouvel album la semaine
prochaine le 4-4 8,8 de l'amour c'est
une adresse fictive
c'est comme un lieu où il ya plein de
belles choses qui se passent l'album est
un prix mars ici musée qu'on sait c'est
avec une chanson qui a été écrite par le
cinéaste et parolier stéphane lafleur
jus de boussole un disque - cci plus
féminin mais plus connu ça seul couac
wii u est plus à couvrir le coût lui
jouer voilà 7 2 a faim je note
aujourd'hui et des mous salle puis oui
ils écoutent salut
je sais
ça
le my jeter
et encore
à
j'ai quand sa vie